정부가 한국은행에 긴급 분석을 요청했습니다.
한은행이 요청한 긴급 분석 내용은
삼성전자 노조가 예고한 총파업이 현실화될 경우
한국 경제에 어떤 충격이 발생할 수 있는지 분석해달라는 요청이었습니다.
이후 한국은행은 관련 긴급 보고서를 총화대와 관계당국에 전달했는데
보고서의 시나리오가 상당히 구체적입니다.
삼성전자 노조가 예고한 총 18일간의 파업이 실제로 진행되고
파업이 끝난 뒤 생산라인을 복구하는 데 추가로 약 3주가 걸릴 경우
반도체 생산 차질 규모가 약 30조 원에 이룰 수 있다는 내용입니다.
이 경우 올해 경제 성장률은 최대 0.5%포인트 낮아지고
GDP 부가가치는 약 15조 원이 줄어들 수 있는 것으로 추산됐습니다.
이 숫자는 단순한 기업 손실 추정이 아닙니다.
한 기업의 파업이 생산, 수출, 협력업체, 금융시장, 그리고 성장률까지 연결될 수 있다는 뜻입니다.
오늘은 이 문제를 노사 갈등의 찬반으로 보지 않겠습니다.
핵심 질문은 하나입니다.
왜 삼성전자 파업이 한국 경제 성장률 0.5% 하락 시나리오까지 이어질 수 있는가?
이 질문을 이해하려면 세 가지를 봐야 합니다.
첫째, 반도체 생산라인이 얼마나 멈추는가?
둘째, 그 충격이 협력업체와 다른 산업으로 얼마나 번지는가?
셋째, 수출 대금이 얼마나 줄어드는가?
이 세 가지가 연결되면 한 기업의 생산 차질이 국가 경제의 수치로 바뀝니다.
먼저 첫 번째입니다.
이번 보고서에서 중요한 부분은 파업 기간만이 아닙니다.
18일 동안 파업을 한다는 것도 큰 변수지만 더 중요한 것은 그 이후입니다.
한은 보고서는 파업 종료 후 생산라인 복구에 약 3주가 걸리는 상황까지 감안했습니다.
즉, 계산은 단순히 18일 동안 생산이 줄어든다가 아닙니다.
파업 기간 플러스 생산라인을 다시 정상 수준으로 돌리는 기간까지를 포함한 겁니다.
반도체 공정은 여러 단계로 이어져 있습니다.
웨이퍼 투입, 노감, 식각, 증착, 세정, 검사, 패키징, 테스트가 순서대로 진행되죠.
그래서 한 공정에서 문제가 생기면 다음 공정으로 넘어갈 수 있는 물량이 줄어듭니다.
앞 공정은 더 이상 밀어넣기 어렵고 뒤 공정은 처리할 물량이 줄어듭니다.
그래서 지금 중요한 건 파업 참여 인원이 몇 명이자가 아닙니다.
어느 공정이 멈추느냐가 더 중요합니다.
전체 직원 중 일부만 빠져도 핵심 공정 인력이 빠지면 생산병목이 생길 수 있습니다.
반대로 파업 규모는?
파업 규모가 커도 핵심 라인이 유지만 된다면 충격은 제한될 수 있겠죠.
그래서 보고서는 생산라인별 가동 중단률을 중요한 변수로 본 겁니다.
이제 파업의 충격이 어느 정도까지 커질 수 있는지 세 가지 경우로 나눠보겠습니다.
가장 낮은 충격의 경우를 생각해 보겠습니다.
파업은 발생하지만 핵심 생산라인은 유지됩니다.
일부 공정에서 지연이 생기고 출하 일정이 늦어질 겁니다.
회사는 재고와 비상 인력을 활용해 충격을 줄입니다.
이 경우에는 기업 실적에는 부담이 생기지만
국가 성장률을 크게 흔드는 수준까지는 가지 않을 가능성이 큽니다.
중간 충격의 경우는 다릅니다.
핵심 공정 일부가 멈춥니다.
그러면 앞뒤 공정이 같이 느려지겠죠.
생산량 감소가 발생하고 납기 일정이 밀립니다.
고객사에 보내야 할 물량이 늦어질 수 있습니다.
이 단계부터는 단순한 사내 문제가 아니라 공급망 문제가 됩니다.
최악의 경우는 주요 생산라인이 상당 기간 멈추고 복구까지 지연되는 상황입니다.
이때는 파업 기간의 손실만 계산하는 것이 아니라
이미 생산 과정에 들어간 물량의 손실, 수요 회복에 걸리는 시간, 고객사 납기 지연, 수출 감소까지 같이 계산해야 합니다.
생산 차질 약 30조 원과 성장률 0.5% 하락이라는 최악의 시나리오는 이런 구조를 전제로 한 숫자입니다.
두 번째로 봐야 할 것은 협력 업체로 번지는 충격입니다.
삼성전자 반도체 생산이 줄어든다고 해서 손실이 삼성전자 안에서만 끝나는 것은 아닙니다.
반도체를 만들기 위해서는 많은 회사들이 함께 움직입니다.
웨이퍼를 공급하는 회사가 있습니다.
소재와 특수 가스를 공급하는 회사가 있습니다.
장비를 관리하는 회사도 있고 물류를 담당하는 회사도 있겠죠.
반도체를 검사하고 포장하는 후공정 업체도 연결되어 있습니다.
그런데 삼성전자의 생산량이 줄어들면 이 회사의 일감도 함께 줄거나 일정이 밀릴 수 있습니다.
여기서 중요한 숫자가 하나 있습니다.
최악의 경우 반도체 생산 차질은 약 30조 원으로 추산됐고
이로 인해 GDP 부가가치는 약 15조 원 줄어들 수 있다는 것으로 계산됐습니다.
그런데 여기서 헷갈리면 안 됩니다.
생산 차질이 30조 원이라고 해서 GDP가 그대로 30조 원이 줄어드는 것은 아닙니다.
생산 차질 30조 원은 쉽게 말해서 원래 만들어서 팔았어야 할 반도체의 총액에 가깝습니다.
하지만 GDP는 매출 전체를 그대로 더하는 지표가 아닙니다.
예를 들어서 반도체 100만 어치를 생산한다고 해보겠습니다.
그 100만 원 안에는 해외에서 들여온 원재료 비용도 있고
이미 구매한 장비와 부품 비용도 있고 전기료와 물류비 같은 중간 비용도 들어갑니다.
이런 비용을 모두 뺀 뒤 국내에서 새로 만들어진 가치만 GDP에 반영합니다.
그래서 생산 차질이 30조 원이라고 해서 30조 원 전체가 GDP 손실로 잡히는 것이 아니라
그 중 국내 부가가치에 해당하는 부분이 GDP 감소로 계산됩니다.
이번 최악의 시나리오에서는 그 규모가 약 15조 원으로 추산된 겁니다.
따라서 삼성전자 생산이 줄면 먼저 총 생산액이 줄어듭니다.
그 다음 협력업체 일감과 수출 물량도 영향을 받습니다.
그 과정에서 생산 차질이 줄어듭니다.
그 과정에서 국내에서 새로 만들어져야 할 가치가 줄어들고
이것이 GDP 부가가치 감소로 이어집니다.
세 번째는 수출 대금 충격입니다.
이 부분이 성장률과 직접 연결됩니다.
한국 경제에서 반도체 수출 비중은 매우 큽니다.
2016년 1분기 한국 수출은 2,199억 달러로 1분기 기준 역대 최대였고
반도체 수출은 785억 달러로 전년 동기 대비 139% 증가했습니다.
반도체가 전체 수출의 35.7%를 차지했다는 부분은
특히 지금은 AI 서버 투자와 메모리 가격 상승이 반도체 수출을 밀어올리고 있는 구간입니다.
DRAM 수출은 전년 동기 대비 249.1% 랜드는 377.5% 증가했습니다.
삼성전자 실적도 같은 흐름입니다.
삼성전자는 2026년 1분기 실적에서
DS 즉 반도체 부분 매출 81.7조원 영업이익 53.7조원을 기록했다고 밝혔습니다.
이 상황에서 삼성전자 반도체 생산이 줄어듭니다.
단순히 기업 매출만 줄어드는 문제가 아닙니다.
수출이 줄을 수 있습니다.
수출이 줄면 달러 유입이 줄어듭니다.
달러 유입이 줄면 무역수지와 경상수지에 부담이 생길 수 있습니다.
그리고 외국인 투자자들은 한국 반도체 공급망의 안정성을 다시 평가할 수밖에 없습니다.
물론 모든 생산 차질이 곧바로 수출 감소로 이어지는 것은 아닙니다.
기존 재고로 일부 대응할 수도 있고
출하가 몇 주 뒤로 밀리는 수준에서 끝날 수도 있습니다.
하지만 AI 반도체와 수출 감소로 이어지는 것은 아닙니다.
하지만 AI 반도체와 수출 감소으로 이어지는 것은 아닙니다.
angry
부가가치가 약 15조원 감소, 성장률 최대 0.5%포인트하라
이 숫자가 나오는 논리는 크게 4단계입니다.
첫째, 생산라인이 멈추면 반도체 생산액이 줄어듭니다.
둘째, 생산액 감소는 협력업체와 관련 산업의 매출 감소로 번집니다.
셋째, 반도체 출하가 줄거나 밀리면 수출 대금 유입이 줄어듭니다.
넷째, 이 모든 효과를 합산하면 GDP 부가가치가 줄고
연간 성장률이 낮아질 수 있습니다.
중요한 점은 이 숫자가 기본 전망이 아니라 최악의 시나리오라는 겁니다.
실제로 파업이 어느 정도 규모로 진행되는지, 핵심 라인이 얼마나 유지되는지,
재고로 얼마나 대응할 수 있는지, 복구가 얼마나 빨리 되는지에 따라
결과는 달라질 겁니다.
따라서 이 문제를 볼 때는 두 가지를 동시에 봐야 합니다.
하나는 노동자의 단체 행동권입니다.
파업은 법적으로 고장된 권리죠.
임금, 성과급, 근로조건에 대해 노동자가 목소리를 내는 것은
민주주의와 시장경제입니다.
삼성전자 반도체는 단순한 개발기업 사업부가 아닙니다.
한국 수출과 제조업 생산, 협력업체 생태계, 외환 흐름, 투자 심리에 영향을 주는 핵심 산업입니다.
그래서 정부가 이 문제를 단순한 노사 갈등으로만 보지 않는 겁니다.
이번 사안의 본질은 어느 한쪽을 비난하는 데 있지 않습니다.
핵심은 한국 경제가 특정 기업과 특정 산업에 얼마나 크게 운송될지,
의존하고 있는지를 확인하는 데 있습니다.
마지막으로 이렇게 정리할 수 있습니다.
삼성전자 파업이 한국 경제를 흔들 수 있다는 말은
삼성전자만 중요하다는 뜻이 아닙니다.
한국 경제의 성장 구조가 반도체 수출에 매우 크게 연결되어 있다는 뜻입니다.
그리고 그 구조가 강점이 될 때는 한국 경제를 빠르게 끌어올리지만
문제가 생길 때는 성장률 전망까지 흔들릴 수 있다는 뜻입니다.
이번 보고서가 던지는 질문은 분명합니다.
한국 경제는 반도체 왕을 어떻게 활용할 것인가?
그리고 동시에 반도체 리스크를
어떻게 줄일 것인가?
이 질문에 대한 답을 찾는 것이
이번 사안을 단순한 노사 갈등이 아니라
경제 구조의 문제로 봐야 하는 이유입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.